RYAN FIORAVANTI: I'm going
to get started now.
Welcome everyone.
My name is Ryan Fioravanti.
I'm here today from the Gmail
team to talk about building
fast mobile web apps.
And if you'd like to follow
along on your laptop or
device, the URL is up here.
You can see the slides at
rjf-io2012.appspot.com OK.
Everyone loves fast stuff,
especially users.
And developers like building
fast things.
Unfortunately, on the mobile
web, it's really
difficult to do.
Today I'm going to try and
present a few things that I
hope you can use to help
build faster mobile web
applications.
When I start looking at
performance work, I like to
approach things in a very
structured manner.
What that means for me is before
I start working on some
improvements, I like to measure
first to prove myself
that there's actually
a problem that
I'm trying to solve.
As I start working on the
problem, I then remeasure
throughout the process to make
sure that I'm making progress
in a way that I'm happy with.
And finally, when I think I'm
done, I'll measure again to
see that I actually had impact
I thought I would.
And if I didn't find an
improvement, I think it's
really important in those
cases to investigate and
figure out why the work that I
did didn't have the impact
that I thought it would.
I seen a lot of people spend a
lot of time trying to make
performance optimizations based
off hunches they have or
ideas, and they spend
a lot of time.
When they're done, it
ends up having no
impact for the users.
And there's no benefit.
So we want to avoid these
kinds of situations.
With this kind of thinking in
mind, this kind of approach, I
decided to structure this
presentation today around a
live website.
So I decided to pick on
html5rocks.com, the mobile version.
And what we're going to do
is do a little bit of
exploration, a little bit of
measurements, to try to
identify what kind of problems
it has, and what kind of fixes
we can make and how much
we can improve this.
So before we start working on
improvements, we first have to
measure to figure out what's
actually wrong.
The best way to do that is by
using a device to do all these
measurements for us.
Now that you all have Chrome on
an Android device, this is
really easy for you to do.
And Chrome on Android comes
with a really neat feature
where you can use the remote
debugger to do profiling on
the device itself.
And this is really useful,
because profiling on your
local desktop browser, for
example, is not at all the
same as profiling on
your mobile device.
The hardware's very different.
The performance is
really different.
And so we really need
to do all this
profiling on a mobile device.
We're also going to install the
PageSpeed extension, and
this is going to help us run
a bunch of automated
analysis on the page.
And hopefully we can get some
quick wins based on its
recommendations.
OK, before we get started out
with PageSpeed or anything
else, we need to define
our success criteria.
So to do that, we need an
accurate way to make some
measurements and figure
out if we're
actually improving anything.
Typically this has been
done in a couple
of ways in the past.
One of the most common ways that
developers would profile
their application or do
measurements for performance
timings, was to add timings in
script blocks for the page.
So it was really common to see
people add a script block at
the top of the document where
they would take a time.
And that would be time zero.
And then they would have timing
throughout the page,
which they could then use the
deltas of to decide how long
certain parts of the page took
for the browser to render.
There's a couple of
problems with this
that we want to avoid.
Number one, just by adding these
measurements to your
page, you can actually have
a negative impact on the
browser's performance.
So just by measuring and looking
at it, you're changing
the situation.
So we want to avoid that.
But also, using this technique,
we were only able
to measure things that were
happening in the browser after
the browser has received
the page content.
We didn't have access to things
like, how long did a
redirect take?
How long did the DNS
lookups take?
How long did the page take to
download from first byte to
the last byte being
sent to the page?
Using this
window.performance.timing
object, we're able to
capture all that
information really easily.
This is an object that's
injected by the browser on
every page load, and it contains
a lot of different
attributes that we can
use to analyze the
full pageload sequence.
So this is really cool.
And we're going to use this in
a bunch of experiments that
we're going to do throughout
this presentation.
The ones I found particularly
interesting from the
experiments I was running
were these four.
So first of all, the most
important one is
navigationStart timing.
This is the exact time that
the user requested for the
page to be loaded.
So this is them clicking a link
to go to your page, or
typing in the URL, or
opening a bookmark.
From the user's perspective,
this is time zero, and
everything after this time is
them sitting there staring at
a white screen, waiting for
your content to appear.
The responseStart event was
the second one that was
interesting to me.
This one is when the browser has
started receiving content.
So this is important because
this tells me when the browser
is able to actually
start doing work.
It's not waiting for the page
to load over the network.
It can start processing
a document, executing
JavaScript, and evaluating
CSS.
The next one is this
domContentLoadedEventStart.
This is basically the
DOMContentReady event.
And this one is important
because this is when your
document becomes interactive and
can start handling events.
And this is our best
approximation for when the
user actually sees something
on the page.
And this is important, because
this is the time that for the
start of this that I'm going to
be optimizing for, for when
the browser gets the page to
when the user sees something.
We want the user to see
something as soon as possible,
because until that point,
they're just staring at a
white screen.
So DOMContentReady means the
user is no longer staring at a
white screen.
The load event is the
window load event.
And this is when the browser's
finished downloading all the
resources on a page, including
the images.
So this is like the final
finish point.
OK.
So we had to set up a baseline
for the experiments before we
start making any performance
improvements.
And this is what
I came up with.
So the way that I set up my
experiments here is, I created
a local copy of html5rocks.com,
the mobile
version, and I set up an
experiment where the browser
would reload the page 50 times
and capture the time from
response start to the
DOMContentReady event.
So what I wanted to optimize
for was just the in-page
rendering, none of the
network stuff.
Just optimizing how fast we
can show the user their
content and stop staring
at the white screen.
And for this experiment, all
the resources are cache,
running on Nexus S hardware,
and using window.reload to
execute the page reloads.
So our baseline here is
1,200 milliseconds.
So 1,200 milliseconds from the
browser getting the first byte
of the document to showing
the user something.
And so that's what we're trying
to improve on now.
And also, 812 kilobytes
transferred for the page.
So the first thing I tried
was PageSpeed.
So you can just open your Chrome
debugger on the Android
device and open up PageSpeed,
and you can run an analysis.
So what it told me right away is
hey, you've got some images
that aren't scaled properly.
So this is a pretty easy fix.
We just have to scale
the images.
So I just modified the local
version to serve up images of
the right size.
The images we were serving were
actually way too big.
They were 369x369 as
opposed to 75x75.
So a lot of wasted
space there.
And also, these were avatar
images, people's photographs,
served up as PNGs.
So I fixed that issue, reran all
my experiments, and these
were the results that I saw.
We had a 2% improvement in
rendering time of the
responseStart event to the DOM
ContentReady, and we saved
about 67 kilobytes.
So this isn't actually the
kind of improvement I was
hoping for.
I thought we were going to be
able to do much better here.
Because we're serving up much
smaller images, and I just
assumed that the browser would
be able to render the page
much more quickly.
But that wasn't actually
the case.
But we did save some
bytes, so that's
good for users' bandwidth.
So at least we have that.
The next thing I realized is,
hey, these are avatars.
We shouldn't be serving
them up as PNGs.
We should be using JPEG.
And with JPEG, we can get much
better compression as well.
So I change the JPEGs and
I remeasured everything.
Here we have another 2%
improvement in rendering time.
We're still talking only about
tens of milliseconds saved.
So this isn't really anything
to get excited about yet.
But we did save another large
chunk of the payload size.
We saved over 300 milliseconds
here, which is a 44%
improvement in the
download size.
So when the resources aren't
cached, the page is going to
load faster, and we're going
to be using less
bandwidth for the users.
So again, no big improvement in
rendering time, but still a
really useful optimization
for us to have made.
Back to PageSpeed.
It's now happy with
the scaled images.
And it's telling us, now you've
got to minify some
JavaScript.
So that's also a pretty
easy fix.
I opened up the network trace,
just to kind of see what
resources it was loading, and
I found that the page was
including the full version
of jQuery.
So that's an easy fix.
I just opened it up, saw that
it's actually the full
version, and then we can just
swap that out with a minified
version, save a bunch
of bytes.
The page functionality
remains the same.
This is a really easy fix to
make because it won't actually
change anything.
And then we can remeasure.
This is the one that surprised
me the most, because here, we
significantly reduced the amount
of JavaScript, but we
didn't actually improve the
rendering time at all.
The rendering time remained
constant from the last set of
experiments.
So that's not good.
But again, we saved some bytes,
so we should do this.
It's the right thing to do.
It'll be faster when the
resources aren't cached, and
that's good.
So I said that we should always
measure before and
after, so that's what
I did here.
And if it doesn't match the
results that you expected, we
should figure out why.
So this is one that really
surprised me.
And I figured out the answer,
and I'm going to show you that
a bit later.
So when you need to minify, this
is something you should
definitely do to save
bytes over the wire.
If you're using a third-party
library, just make sure you're
pulling in the right version
for your production
environment.
So you usually want to include
the [? dead ?] version in your
local setup.
But when you deploy to
production, you should have
some kind of build phase where
you swap it out with the
minified version.
And that's easy to do.
If you're writing a lot of
your own JavaScript, then
you're going to have to do
your own minification.
This is something that
you can also set up
into your build phase.
There's a couple of tools you
can download as command-line
tools that you can run
on your files.
You run this tool, and
it spits out the
minified version for you.
Or if you just want to quickly
minify some stuff and you
don't want to download anything
to get this set up,
there's an online version as
well that you can try.
You just drop some JavaScript
into a text area, click a
button, and then you'll get
the minified version.
OK.
So the next thing that
I wanted to try--
we're done with PageSpeed now.
We've satisfied all of
its recommendations.
The next thing that I
wanted to try is to
run some CSS profiling.
So using this, I can take a look
at exactly how expensive
my CSS rendering is for the
browser to execute.
So to do this, open up your
developer tools on the Android
device, go over to the Profiles
tab, select the CSS
Selector profile,
and click Start.
And this will start a recording
of how expensive
your CSS is.
So what I did here
is I did that.
I clicked start, started
recording, and then reload the
page, and then I stopped
the recording.
And this tells me how expensive
the CSS is during
the pageload.
And here's the results.
So here we get a breakdown of
exactly how expensive every
single CSS rule is in my style
sheets during a pageload.
So it's telling me here,
this rule at the top--
I've sorted by the total time
taken for each rule--
the rule at the top is taking
over 50 milliseconds for the
browser to evaluate while
the page is loading.
This is rendering time that the
browser is spending before
showing the user any content.
So it's telling me, just by
fixing this rule, I can save
the user 50 milliseconds
in wait time.
So that's pretty cool.
And there's also a bunch more
rules here that are over 20
and 30 milliseconds.
So if I fixed all of those, I'd
be looking at hundreds of
milliseconds in savings.
So that's something I'm
interested in, so I dug a
little further.
Before I show exactly what was
wrong, I'll talk a little bit
about what can make CSS
expensive on mobile.
Mainly, it all boils down to how
many elements is your CSS
selector matching?
So if you're matching all
elements in your document,
that's going to be really
expensive for the
browser to work with.
This is why the universal
selector is so bad on mobile,
because the browser has to apply
that to every element in
your document.
Also, ancestor rules are
pretty expensive.
Because when it finds a match
for the right-most element in
the selector, it has to search
the ancestor tree of that
element, further qualifying to
find a match for that rule.
So what I've got here, this body
* rule-- this is about
the worst CSS rule you
could possibly write.
This is the universal
selector matching
everything in the document--
which we already know we
shouldn't do on mobile-- but
also with an ancestor selector
of the body.
So the browser has to enumerate
every single element
in the document, and then search
the ancestor tree of
that element to ensure that it
has an ancestor of type body.
So this is really expensive,
and it's also wasteful,
because of course every
element's in the body.
We really don't need to
qualify for this.
Here's some examples of ways you
can change your CSS from
bad to good for these
different cases.
So first of all, we know
we want to avoid
the universal selector.
The way to avoid this is to
just realize that most the
time, you don't actually
need it.
Say, for example, you want to
apply a consistent font to
your entire document.
You don't need to use the
universal selector to do that
because CSS has this
cascading nature.
You just apply the font rule
to your body, and then your
entire document will naturally
inherit that rule.
So that's an easy fix.
For [? considered ?]
rules, these are pretty standard
rules, the ul li.
If you want to color all of your
list items blue, that's a
pretty standard way to do
it, when we learn CSS.
But if you swap that out with
a specific class name called
unordered-list-item that you
manually apply to all of your
li elements in the document
that are children of ul
elements, this will
execute much
faster on mobile hardware.
And you will see a difference.
Lastly, don't include CSS rules
that set things that are
default values.
Like here, I've got div
set to display block.
Just let the browser
figure that out.
If you're trying to save some
rare user agents that might
have screwed this up, then I
would say, just let most of
your browsers be fast
and let broken
browsers be broken browsers.
So back to the example,
html5rocks.com, we had that
50-millisecond timing
on one rule.
It turns out that it was
specifying a default CSS
property, setting the
box sizing of every
element in the document.
So this one is really easy.
Because it's a default
property, we
can just remove it.
The page will have the
same behavior.
And we can figure out what
kind of impact it had.
So here we go.
Approximately 50 milliseconds
saved in rendering time.
That's just about exactly
what we expected.
That was nice to see.
I was comforted by this, because
the profiler told me,
when I measured before, that I
would save 50 milliseconds if
I fixed this rule.
And then when I measured after,
that was confirmed.
So what this means is that the
profiler is doing an accurate
job of predicting exactly how
much my users will save in
time if I fix those rules.
So that's good to know.
So if you are planning on
setting out for a couple of
days or a week to optimize the
CSS on your page, you can be
sure that you should definitely
open up your CSS
profiler and check, are there
actually any problems?
And if not, then you can just
skip that whole process.
OK.
So what's next?
Remember what we're
trying to do here.
We want to optimize the time for
which the user is sitting
there waiting, looking
at a white screen.
From the time the browser gets
the page to the time they want
to see content, we want to get
rid of everything on that
critical path.
So if we look at the network
trace in your developer tools,
you can see exactly when that
DomReady event is firing.
That's the blue line.
So this is our approximation
for when the
user is seeing content.
Everything on the left of this
is just getting in the way.
So we need to make sure that
everything over here is
something that's critical to
showing our user content.
So here's the first resource.
Obviously this is critical.
This is the main markup
of the page.
Our CSS is pretty critical.
We don't want to show people
just plain HTML.
But then the rest of these are
all JavaScript files that are
loading over the network and
taking time to execute.
So on html5rocks.com, this
is just a plain website.
We don't need to include all
these scripts before we show
the user something.
And the problem with these is
just the presence of the
scripts on the page that's
slowing down the
DOMContentReady event.
When you include a script on
your page, the browser doesn't
actually know when it should
do something with it.
It doesn't know if you need that
script immediately, or if
you just need it 10
seconds from now.
So what it does is it downloads
it immediately,
before doing anything else,
before it proceeds with the
rest of your document,
and then executes
it right away, too.
So in this case, we don't need
that kind of behavior.
We can defer this JavaScript
until later.
So we can do something here in
order to get rid of that.
So what we need is a way to
defer this JavaScript in a
reliable manner.
I looked at a couple
of ways to do this.
First, I tried the
defer attribute.
This didn't work well for me.
I tried it and it worked, but
when I reran my experiments,
it didn't actually
help anything.
When I investigated a little
deeper to find out what was
happening, I found a lot of
resources suggesting that the
defer attribute is more like a
suggestion to the browser.
So it can defer it if it thinks
that's a good idea, or
it'll execute in parallel
to those idle cycles.
I also found a bunch of stuff
that it's not good
cross-browser, and
all this stuff.
But the point is, it just
didn't really work well.
It didn't speed up the
page-rendering time.
I then looked at async
attribute, and this had some
different behavior, where
it would defer the
loading of the scripts.
But they would load in at any
order, not necessarily the
order that you included
them on the page.
So this can lead to some race
conditions where you get
JavaScript errors.
Say, you have some inline
script running jQuery
functions before the jQuery
file gets loaded.
Then that's not going
to work properly.
So what I did is, I cooked up
a way you can include a
special type on your script
attribute that tricks the
browser into thinking that
this isn't actually
JavaScript.
So what we have here, is I've
just stamped all these script
elements with a special
type called notJs.
And so now these scripts will
actually download over the
network, but the browser will
just pass over these and not
do anything with it, because
it doesn't know what it is.
And then when you want to load
these scripts, you can just
include this simple bit
of script here.
What this does is it loads all
the scripts in the document,
and loops through them.
If the type is notJs, then
it sets the type back to
text/javascript and then it
re-adds it to the document.
When you do this, the document
reevaluates it, parses it
right away because now it sees
that it's JavaScript, and
executes it just as
we would expect.
So what I've done is, I modified
the experiments.
I created this function.
I added notJs to all the
scripts on the page.
And then I set this
function to be the
window.onload function.
Here's the results.
Oooh.
So our page running time
just got a lot faster.
We have a 33% improvement in
running time, and this is
hundreds of milliseconds.
But remember, all these
resources are cached.
That's how we're running
these experiments.
So why does this take so long?
It takes so long because it
takes one millisecond to parse
every kilobyte of JavaScript
on modern mobile hardware.
And this is really important.
What I mean by parse is, when
the browser encounters a
script block, this is the time
that it takes to read all the
text in that script block and
figure out what it means in
terms of JavaScript, and then
execute on the top-level lines
of JavaScript in that
script function.
And this is much more expensive
to do on mobile than
it is on desktop.
Here's a more detailed breakdown
of some of the
experiments that my team has run
to investigate what kind
of parse times we see
across devices.
So you can see here, for Nexus
S hardware, it takes 300
milliseconds to parse 300
kilobytes of JavaScript.
And that's where we get our
one millisecond to one
kilobyte rule.
And 300K is a pretty average
amount of JavaScript to
include on a page, especially
for pages that have kind of
been ported over from desktop,
where we just include lots of
JavaScript all the time and
it doesn't really matter.
And 300 milliseconds is a long
time for a user to wait,
sitting and staring at a white
screen, seeing nothing,
waiting for your page to load.
Now what's really interesting
is looking back a few
generations in phone hardware.
And we see that iPhone 2G would
take over three seconds
to parse the same amount
of JavaScript.
And that's a 10x improvement in
just a few generations of
phone hardware.
So what we're seeing is a trend
where phone hardware is
improving drastically,
very quickly.
And so this should play--
you should keep this in mind.
It should play a pretty big role
in how you think about
performance optimizations.
Now let's think back--
our jQuery example.
We minified jQuery, and we saved
over 100 kilobytes in
JavaScript, but we saw no
improvement in rendering time.
So why was that?
So in this table, you'll see--
or maybe you won't see--
these are for minified
JavaScript sizes.
So when we minified our jQuery
file from 240 kilobytes to 90
kilobytes, we didn't actually
make it any less complex for
the browser to parse.
It's still the same
JavaScript.
It still has the same level of
complexity, the same amount of
stuff to execute, and the same
amount of stuff for the
browser to figure out.
So just by minifying it, we
didn't actually save anything
in parse time.
So that makes sense.
What this also means is that you
shouldn't just minify your
JavaScript.
You should compile it.
Using tools like Closure
Compiler, you can run phases
like the dead code removal in
order to get rid of all the
JavaScript on your page that's
not actually being used.
So when you're pulling in
libraries like jQuery and
using only a small fraction of
it, you can use compilers to
remove all the stuff that you're
not actually using.
And when you do that, that's
when you're going to see
improvements in parse time.
OK, so how much faster
can we go now?
We have optimized images,
optimized CSS, and no
JavaScript getting in the way
of our content rendering.
The only thing we could do now
is get rid of styles, which we
probably don't want to do, or
send down a smaller DOM.
So we could just say to our
designers, hey, your
document's too big.
I don't want to show
this much content.
It's really expensive
on mobile.
And maybe that's acceptable.
But say it's not.
There's still something
that you can do.
Here's a little trick.
We're going to lazy load a
bunch of the document.
So we can send down large
portions of the document and
only show a little bit
when we're first
rendering the page.
The html5rocks.com main
page, it's got a lot
of scrollable content.
So there's a lot of stuff when
the user loads the page that's
there, but they can't
actually see.
So there's no reason for us to
actually demand that the
browser try and render
that right away.
So what I've done here is I took
a couple of the top-level
elements on the web page and
set them to display:none,
which just takes it out of the
rendering process completely.
Then on the pageload, we can
just set these back to
display:visible and they'll
show up right away.
So they'll be there by the time
the user scrolls down to
try and use those parts
of the page.
And by doing this, we've made
the page significantly simpler
for the browser to render, and
now we've saved another couple
hundred milliseconds
in rendering time.
So now we're sitting at 600
milliseconds of render time.
So remember, that's time from
the browser getting the page
to showing user content.
And that's just about a 2x
improvement since we started
these optimizations.
So at this point I'm
pretty happy.
And I don't know that there's
much more we can do on just
the rendering, other
than waiting
for newer phone hardware.
We could maybe squeeze out
another 50 or 100 milliseconds
in this rendering time by really
digging into the CSS or
simplifying the DOM a little bit
more, and stuff like that.
But at this point, our effort
is probably better spent
optimizing other things.
So, so far we've only been
looking at the rendering
performance, but there's
actually a lot more variables
that the user waits on, other
than just the rendering.
We need to consider things like
the network load time and
redirects and all this
kind of stuff.
And optimizing for these is
really hard to do on your
local development environments,
because the
environment is completely
different from the production
environment.
So to figure out what real
users in the wild are
experiencing, there's this
cool website called
webpagetest.org, where you can
go and they've got a browser
farm, and you can type
in any website URL.
It will load the page and tell
you exactly what kind of load
sequence your page has.
So these are results for
html5rocks.com using one of
their Android browsers in
the mobile browser farm.
So here we can see exactly
what's happening on pageload.
We've got two redirects here,
and then here's the main
pageload, and then all these
resources loading.
And here's the rest of
the waterfall chart.
So right away, we can see
exactly how much time we could
save the users by optimizing
different
parts of this process.
For example, why do we
need two redirects?
We can just get rid of one of
these redirects, and we would
automatically save 100
milliseconds right there.
But it looks like the biggest
performance improvements we
could make here are
on this pageload.
It's taking over 1.7 seconds
to download this page.
That's pretty terrible.
Also, interestingly, is that
these browsers and the browser
farm are all on a strong
Wi-Fi connection.
So it's not like this is
downloading over an Edge
network and taking
a long time.
This is probably taking over
a second just in server
processing time.
So if we really want to make a
difference for our users, we
would look at this information
and dig into our server
infrastructure and figure out
why it's taking over a second
to process requests and
start sending the
first byte to the browser.
And here's the green line--
this is the load event.
And you can see there's
a bunch of
JavaScript files loading.
This is what we've pushed over
onto the other side of the
Ready event.
And remember that we saved 600
milliseconds, which is maybe
about like this much.
And we said that the only
further improvements we can
make there are pretty
marginal.
So definitely, looking at this
huge chunk here, this is what
we would want to focus on if we
want to help our users out.
OK.
So what if we decide improving
the server is hard?
I want to do this
from the client.
We actually can do that
by using AppCache.
And using AppCache, we can
entirely get rid of the
network time and bring that
to zero, because all the
resources will be
cached locally,
including the HTML file.
To set this up, you just need to
create a manifest file and
link it to your HTML
attribute here.
You host this manifest file
on your web server.
And in this manifest file, you
describe all the resources
that you want to be cached.
So when we add that to the
page and rerun the
experiments, we see that
we've actually
taken a rendering hit.
And so this was important
and a little bit of
a surprise to me.
Upon investigation, I realized
that what was happening was,
the manifest file was
downloading every pageload.
Even if all the resources are
cached, the browser has to
re-download this manifest file
every time it opens the page,
and that's because the manifest
serves as the
indication to the browser as to
when it needs to update the
resources because the
application's out of date.
So when the developer changes
the manifest file, that means
the app needs to be updated and
re-download all the resources.
But what it means for a normal
pageload sequence is that
we've downloaded the page and
the first thing the browser
processes is the HTML node.
And it sees the manifest
attribute, and then right then
and there, it starts
downloading
this AppCache file.
So that means while you're on
the critical path of trying to
render your content, you've
initiated a new download
happening in parallel.
So you're creating resource
contention, and that's why we
see the rendering hit.
However, this is pretty
acceptable, given that we're
saving, as we saw, almost two
seconds in network load time.
So that pretty far offsets the
tens of milliseconds that
we're losing here.
So AppCache sounds
pretty easy.
I'm making it sound like a
silver bullet to improving
your network time.
But that's not actually
the case.
It can be a real challenge.
It can be a real nuisance, and
there's lots of things that
can go wrong.
Let's talk about why.
And it requires a little bit
deeper understanding of how
AppCache works.
So what we're doing here is
looking at the Resources tab.
This is showing us the AppCache
entry for the site on
the local version that
I've created.
These are all the files that
have been added to this
AppCache entry.
The manifest file is the key to
the AppCache entry the maps
all the resources that are
cached in this entry.
So all the resources that you
list in the manifest file--
you can find them all here.
These are the explicit
entries here.
All of the HTML files that point
to this manifest file
end up in here as
master entries.
So if you have 10 pages on your
site, all pointing to the
same manifest file, they'll
all appear here as master
entries in your AppCache
entry.
And then remember, when the
manifest file changes, that's
the signal to the browser to
re-download the resources
because the developer has
published an update to this
application.
So when that happens, you can
see how the browser behaves by
looking at the developer
console when you're
refreshing the page.
So what happens is the browser
sees the manifest file has
changed and then initiates
an AppCache update and
re-downloads all these
resources.
And what we see here is that
it's downloading these two
HTML files at the same time.
Let's look at an example of
why this can be so bad.
Number one, user opens
a single page with
five external resources.
Let's say that totals 350
kilobytes of downloaded stuff.
That goes into the
AppCache entry.
The user then opens 10 more
pages on the site.
Each of them are
200 kilobytes.
All of these go into
the AppCache entry.
Now we've published an update to
the web app by changing the
manifest file.
The user visits just one
of these 11 pages.
The browser checks the manifest
file, sees a change,
and initiates an AppCache
update.
Now, what happens is the browser
downloads over 2
megabytes of data in the
background, just by navigating
to this one page.
Say you had 10,000
users that day.
You're serving up over 20
gigabytes of data versus what
should have been only 20
megabytes of data if they were
just loading those HTML
files by themselves.
So not only could this be really
expensive for your
users, but it can be really
expensive to you, depending on
your server infrastructure.
OK.
So how can we get around this?
The obvious solution seems to
be, let's include one manifest
file per HTML page.
So for every page we're serving
up, it's going to have
its own manifest file, it'll
have its own AppCache entry,
and everything will be good.
That's not actually
the case either.
When you create several AppCache
entries, you can use
Chrome, go into AppCache
Internals, and see how you're
kind of affecting the
various AppCache
entries in the system.
So what I've done is I've
modified the local version to
have several AppCache files for
those two HTML files that
we were previously loading
in a single entry.
What we see here is this one
here is over 350 kilobytes in
size, and this one is also
very large, over 260.
And what's happening is that all
of the external resources
that our manifest files are
pointing to are being cached
in both of these AppCache
entries.
So the AppCache entries can't
share external resources
amongst themselves.
They need to cache
all the files
explicitly in each entry.
And so the sizes of these
are adding up quickly.
And the reason that's a problem
is because the browser
has a hard limit of 5 megabytes
per domain quota for
your AppCache space.
So just based on the pace that
we're going here, for
html5rocks.com, by only adding
10 pages to this AppCache
setup, we would exceed
that limit already.
And what happens when you
exceed the limit is, the
browser tries to download the
updates, and when it gets the
update it tries to push
it into the cache.
But when you've exceeded
your quota, that
push will just fail.
And there's nothing that you
can really do about it
programmatically
in JavaScript.
If your users get into this
situation, they can actually
get stuck on a really stale
version of their site, because
they can't actually update
to the new version.
So this is a pretty big
problem that you
should try to avoid.
And if you get into this
problem, you're kind of
screwed, because you can't
fix it after the fact.
The only thing that you can do
is serve 404s on your AppCache
requests, and this invalidates
the AppCache in the browser.
So it used to seem
really easy.
Now it seems really hard.
How can we actually
make this work?
You have three options,
basically.
You can decide to only include
a manifest file on
a select few pages.
So this means, maybe, your home
page or just a few really
important pages include
a manifest
file and use AppCache.
So this is acceptable, maybe,
depending on your product
requirements.
But what this does is basically
limit the scope on
how big your AppCache
entry can get.
The next thing that you can
try is to implement your
entire site as a single page.
So this is more what those like,
webapps apps do, where
it's just a single
HTML/JavaScript/CSS bundle
sent to the client.
Gmail and Twitter are both good
examples of single-page
sites that use AppCache.
And when you're doing this, you
don't run into the problem
of many pages, because you
only have one page.
And the other option is to just
not use AppCache at all.
Google Search uses a really cool
technique where they want
to cache lots of resources,
but they want those to be
cached across all their URLs,
because when you do a search,
it modifies the URL so that's
shareable and things.
And so they're saving a lot of
stuff in localStorage and
caching their resources that
way, such that they're
available across all pages.
OK, so let's change
gears a bit.
So far we've only talked,
really, about page load and
rendering time.
The next really important
thing on mobile is event
handling time.
Basically, everything that
happens after your page is
loaded is an event handler
of some sort.
And so what I really want to
focus on here is the user does
some kind of interaction on the
page, and then we execute
some JavaScript and publish an
update to the applications and
we change the DOM so the user
sees something happen.
So there's a couple of
high-level guidelines here.
First of all, everything on the
DOM is slow, so touch it
as little as possible.
And when you do touch it, we
want to batch all of the DOM
changes together.
If you were at the Jank
Busting talk that just
happened an hour ago, they
showed a couple of really cool
ways that you could debug
these kind of issues.
And this is a little
bit of the same
thing, but kind of different.
So here's an example of a really
bad event handler.
And this is how you can debug
it and see what's going on.
So using the Events timeline,
we see, here
is the event handler.
And I've expanded this, and
now we can see what's
happening in this
event handler.
And what we see here--
these are Recalculate
Style events.
What we see here is we executed
some JavaScript and
then we have a style
recalculation.
Then we execute some more, and
we have a style recalculation.
And every time there's a style
recalculation, this is what's
really expensive, especially
on mobile.
This is where the browser
says hey, wait, I
gotta update stuff.
And it basically does a reflow
of the entire document to
calculate how large all the
blocks on the page are.
And that's why we see this
big time gap here.
This time here is the browser
just taking time to
lay itself out again.
And then we have another reflow
here, and another one.
And then here's the
Paint event here.
And this is the real goal of
the event handler, is to
respond to the user's event and
Paint as soon as possible.
Here's the code that is the
implementation of this really
bad event handler.
So what we have here is a
bunch of DOM mutations
sprinkled throughout
the event handler.
And this is exactly what
we want to avoid.
And then what we have is, we're
looking at offsetWidth
on one of these divs.
And using offsetWidth is
something that requires the
browser to know how large
things are on the page.
So it needs to do a style
recalculation.
So each one of these offsetWidth
statements here is
what causes the style
recalculation and is what's
making this event
handler so slow.
Here's a reimplementation just
simply rearranging this
function so that it performs
significantly better.
All of the DOM mutations
are batched together.
And then based on these
statements here, we'll only
end up with one style
recalculation.
So here's what it
looks like now.
The event handler fires, we
execute a bunch of JavaScript,
we have one style recalculation,
and
then we do our Paint.
And so this is significantly
faster and will end up being
much more responsive feedback to
our user, because the Paint
happened so much closer
as to when they
interacted with the page.
Here's the performance impact
this can actually have.
So I ran just this simple bad
code snippet on desktop Chrome
1,000 times.
And it took nine seconds for the
bad case and 2.5 seconds
for the good implementation.
This is a 72% improvement in
the processing time of this
event handler.
So that's really significant.
And then on mobile, I ran it
100 times on Chrome for
Android, and similarly, I saw
66% improvement in the
handling time.
So this is really
important to do.
For any time that your user on
your touch-based mobile web
application--
when they touch something, they
want to see an update as
soon as possible.
Because they a), want things to
be fast, but b), when they
touch it, they need that kind
of tactile feedback in order
to feel like the application is
really performing properly.
So the next thing that can
really hurt your interaction
speed is the 300 millisecond
problem.
This is the problem where all
click events on mobile
browsers come 300 milliseconds
after the user actually taps
the screen.
And the reason that browsers
do this is because they're
waiting to see if the user taps
the screen again, which
would indicate a double-tap.
And so a double-tap on mobile
browsers will perform a
zoom-in operation, and so that's
why they introduced
this delay.
For us, if we're creating an app
and we have a button, we
don't really want to have
to support the user
zooming in on a button.
We just want that button to
respond as fast as possible.
And by the time 300 milliseconds
executes, we're
way too late already.
There's nothing we can do.
No matter how efficient our
event handler is, it's going
to be too slow.
So the way we fix this is
actually really hackey.
I've got a code snippet here
that kind of illustrates how
we can do this.
This overrides the default
functionality of the click
event, sets up touchend event
listeners on the button, and
then on the touchend we'll do
whatever click behavior we
wanted the button to do
in the first place.
And then you can get a handle on
your buttons throughout the
application in JavaScript
and decorate
them with this behavior.
And all of a sudden,
your buttons will
be magically fast.
So I make this code seem really
simple, but there's
actually a lot of problems and
glitches that it introduces,
and considerations.
So for more details, check out
this article that I wrote a
while ago on creating fast
buttons for mobile web
applications.
It explains all of the things
that you need to keep in mind
while you're working
with this approach.
And if you don't want to have
to write code yourself,
because developers are lazy,
which is good, you can pull up
this implementation here on
html5boilerplate.com/mobile
and you can just drop
this into your app
and start using it.
OK.
So the next thing that we want
to be able to do when we're
providing user with DOM updates
is to make sure, if
we're doing animations and
things like that, that they're
as smooth as possible.
Which will make the user
happy, hopefully.
And so the way that we need to
do that is make sure that all
of our animations and
document updates are
hardware-accelerated
when necessary.
So hardware-accelerated means
that you're going to take an
element, and it's going to be
turned into a layer that will
be uploaded to the GPU
for processing
off the main thread.
And this is what allows
it to be really
smooth and really fast.
Making something
hardware-accelerated in your
document is kind of
magical today.
You just have to do something to
put it into some 3D space,
and that will hopefully make
it hardware-accelerated.
So you can create a class
like this in your CSS
rules called .hwaccel.
Webkit-transform is the
identity transform.
And you can apply this
to elements.
It won't move it anywhere on the
page, but now updates to
this element will be
hardware-accelerated.
Now if you're moving
elements, you can
create a different class.
You can move elements using the
positioning attributes,
like left or top.
But it's actually much faster to
use the transform property
to move elements.
So this will ensure
the best hardware
acceleration possible.
So what we have here is a
little CSS rule to make
something transitionable.
We've applied transition,
which will be on
the transform property.
This transition will take 200
milliseconds to execute and
we'll use an easing function.
OK.
So we're going to put these
three ideas together now.
The three ideas were efficient
event handling, solving the
300-millisecond problem, and
smooth updating of elements
using hardware acceleration.
So consider a scenario.
In your mobile web app, you've
got a button, and when the
user taps that button, you
want to do a view slide
transition to the next page.
And you want this to happen
as fast as possible.
The next page isn't
rendered yet.
So we need to render it when
the user taps this.
And the next page needs to
become interactive as well.
So not only do we need to render
it, but we need to add
a bunch of event listeners to
it, and maybe load in some
images, and stuff like that.
So here's a nice approach
we can take.
First of all, we'll set up a
couple of CSS rules for our
two pages that will make
them transitionable.
Next we'll take our button and
make it a fast button to avoid
the 300 millisecond problem.
Now when the tap event occurs,
we'll get a handle on the
current page and
the next page.
We'll render the next page,
but we're going to be very
careful to only do a minimal
amount of rendering possible.
So we don't want to render
everything, because that will
take too long.
We want to start this animation
as soon as possible.
We then apply our transform
properties, because using
transforms is the better way
to reposition an element.
And we're going to do it such
that the current page animates
off the screen and the next page
animates onto the screen.
Remember, we want to make the
next page interactive.
As soon as we apply these
transforms, the
animation will start.
But we still have to do
additional work on the next
page to load in those extra
resources, images, maybe, and
add event listeners to it.
So we can add an event listener
which will fire as
soon as the transition ends.
And when it does, now this is
the appropriate time to do all
that additional rendering
and event setup.
So what we have here
is probably
the ideal event handler.
It's a fast button.
We do a minimal amount
of DOM changes.
And all of our DOM changes
are batched together.
And then we defer all of the
expensive work until after the
animation starts.
And our animation is
hardware-accelerated.
So that's all I have
for you today.
Here's a summary of the various
optimizations that we did.
And some of them were a little
bit surprising, so again,
that's why it's really good
that we measure things.
So we don't just assume what's
going to happen.
We confirm that it behaves
as expected.
And these are some of the
tools that we looked at.
Chrome dev tools, PageSpeed,
and webpagetest.org.
And if you're going to remember
anything, please
remember, don't waste
your time.
Always measure before
and after.
Verify all of your
assumptions.
And optimize what will make a
difference, not just what's
interesting to work on.
OK.
Thank you very much.
I'll happily take some questions
if people want.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
RYAN FIORAVANTI: I can also
stick around for a bit after,
if people would like
to talk in person.
But if you want to ask a
question in front of everyone,
just step up to the mic.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if you
know if jQuery mobile uses
most of the optimizations that
you were just showing.
RYAN FIORAVANTI: jQuery
mobile, I know--
I'm pretty sure they have the
tab functionality, like making
buttons fast.
I've also seen that they've
worked a lot on view
transitions and things.
When you're using these
frameworks, they can try and
do a lot of stuff for you.
But based on all of your
integration points, it's
really easy to introduce
slow points.
So it's really important, even
if you're using all these
libraries, that you really dig
and understand what can make
your app slow.
And look at if it's
being slow.
Maybe jQuery mobile does do
all of this stuff, but you
have to confirm that you're
using it properly.
Because there's so much you
can do to screw it up.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I have a question about your
really interesting technique
for making the JavaScript
load later by making
it a different type.
I've seen a lot of people do the
technique where they put
the JavaScript at the
bottom of the page
instead of in the head.
How does that play into
the decision?
RYAN FIORAVANTI: Yeah, so I
tried moving the JavaScript to
the bottom of page.
When it's at the bottom of the
page, the browser has just
finished receiving the
entire document.
And so it's not clear whether
it's being painted or not.
And it then encounters the
JavaScript, which may or may
not be mutating the DOM.
So it then executes
all of that.
So when I did that, it didn't
actually have an impact on my
experiments at all.
And it kind of makes sense.
Like if your script at the
bottom is going to change
everything in the document, then
the browser should wait
for that so that you can show
the user the proper content.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What tool
did you use to get
the repeated pageloads?
RYAN FIORAVANTI: So at first--
I'll be honest--
I was actually just refreshing
the page and looking at some
of the timing output
in the dev console.
But then I got much smarter and
I created a loop, kind of,
where the page would load and
then it would take my timing.
I would save that in
localStorage and then I would
call window.location.reload.
And also in localStorage, I
would save the number of times
I ran this.
So when that counter
got to 50--
because I was running
50 samples--
then I would stop calling
reload, and I would just stop,
and I would alert the
average of all the
times that I was tracking.
So, no tool.
I just wrote something
that used
localStorage pretty quickly.
OK.
Thanks everybody.